alors parler de vous parce qu'on a parlé
de vous dimanche dernier mois je pensais
donne je rappelle aux téléspectateurs
s'ils n'ont pas vu le dr séquence de
dimanche dernier
philippe noiret était là pour présenter
son dernier film très beau film
d'ailleurs moi je pense vous donner un
coup de main en diffusant and la bande
annonce de votre film qui est sorti le
12 janvier tout est calme noirs et fait
un commentaire et il lui rend hommage
votre travail pas tous vos films
certains il les trouve le jeu le site à
chier mais d'autres très bons et puis
parle de vous et il dit que vous montez
sur votre patrimoine et alors là vous
savez ça vous a mis en colère
oui parce que si vous voulez je n'ai pas
vu noir et depuis 22 ans d'une pizza où
j'ai tourné le témoin et et moi ce que
je crains c'est que noir et malgré que
vous dites qu'il a fait un film très
bien qui n'est plus un rond qui soit
dans le désespoir le plus total et parce
que quand il dit que moi j'ai un compte
en banque supérieur au sien ça veut dire
que le sien est nul puisque moi j'ai pas
grand chose donc l'huile à rien alors
comment il paye ses cigares c'est chaud
etc
il faut faire une collecte en sa faveur
j'ai voilà bon alors évidemment vous
avez 3 si j'ose dire à un droit de
réponse à laquelle vous êtes là ce que
vous avez été attaqué un peu perso qua
non parce que là veut dire que moi qui
n'ai pas de publicité dans mes peux pas
payer mes mais pu me là vous voyez mon
film vient de sortir il va ressortir de
la fiche il s'en va cette semaine sauf
de mon cinéma parce que j'ai aucune
publicité en dehors des chaînes de télé
via des interviews
nous n'avons pas d'argent pour payer
alors imaginer que si j'avais du pognon
j'en mettrais un peu par orgueil
simplement
et pourquoi il a dit ça alors évident
parce que là les techniciens étaient
parfois travail c'est là il est gelé
mais en participation et j'aurais
j'aurais sipa des lingots d'or dans une
cave et ses amis les cinglés pas ce que
ça peu mais je crois que ça vient d'eux
d'une dispute parce qu'il est du côté
des gens qui trouvent que les critiques
sont pas bien moi je dis que les
critiques mais là il vient de me donner
un coup de main encore je peux pas être
contre les critiques et lui appartient
petit un petit groupe qui qui dit que
les critiques et yvan un peu fort etc
je me demande si c'est pas une petite
vengeance personnelle parce que c'est
pas un mauvais gars noiret
autre film qui s'appelle tout est calme
dont on a parlé dimanche dernier donc il
est sorti le 12 janvier
oui c'est ça et là ils sont en bas de la
fiche sauf du num d'ubs a dit qui aime
où j'ai eu le plaisir hier s'il ya un
complet qui monte cinéma mais si vous
possédez alors là il ya tant de marée va
dire c'est notamment possédé je possède
le bail un wagon j'ai piqué qui donne
une très peu et et le loyer est de 8000
balle par mois que vous payez que je
paye d'accord est clair ce n'est pas
vous c'est pas ça vous appartient pas
mais allez y à un mec qui disait que
j'avais sans pizzeria parce que j'avais
prêté un jour trente mille balles à un
mec pour faire une pizzeria voyez un peu
comment alors peut-être que noir et l'a
entendu le film est sorti de la fiche
pourquoi parce que pu éviter cela c'est
parce que parce qu'il n'ya pas au public
s'il en avait 30 personnes mercredi 30
personnes aux champs elysées avec une
belle affiche que vous venez et parce
qu'il n'y a pas de pub
alors les gens se disent merde [ __ ]
moque il il n'a pas de pub
ils entendent que j'allais du pognon
d'après noir et donc ils se disent
qu'est ce que c'est que ce con il sort
un film et il n'y a pas de yahia ya pas
de pub
il ya personne ne sait que le fait même
ma concierge sait pas que le film est
sorti parce qu'ils lisent pas les gens
alors qu'aujourd'hui elle le sera grâce
à vous alors que pourquoi votre avis
parce que on trouve que votre cinéma
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas aussi performant
que celui d'hier ou parce qu'il ya
d'autres réseaux nombre de fonds ce
sujet là un ce sujet là c'est les mornes
les mallory faut rappeler le sujet est
mort naturelle qui ne le sont pas
légales d'être des hommes politiques on
parle de l'est on a parlé de l'aider dit
coluche et ses poulains de bérégovoy de
maxwell et moi je parle de ça et ça fait
chier tout le monde alors finalement
métaux fin mai mais oliver stone a aux
etats unis ils étaient tous fait aussi
c'est à dire qu'on peut plus parler bois
c'était la télé d'accord et non moi je
reste tout seul à parler de trucs comme
ça merde alors après on me dit que j'ai
du pognon alors non si je voulais avoir
du pognon comme noiret qui touche de
sambre bâton par film moi je touche rien
du tout ses films sont gratos alors ça
va pas ça va pas et maintenant je vais
faire d'autres films parce que je
voulais faire mais sur les rillettes là
combien on vient de tuer des mecs
bon alors maintenant je vais faire mais
seriez tous les mecs vont me tomber sur
la gueule en me disant mais de quoi tu
parles pourquoi c'est pas vrai on
empoisonne pas les gens etc
j'aurais pu j'aurais pas de pognon pour
le faire voilà autrement dit
vous êtes mis en quarantaine parce que
vous seriez le dernier révolté quoi le
dernier et ils attachent mais il ya des
journalistes qui peuvent pas dire ce que
je dis il ya des journalistes qui savent
des trucs qui peuvent pas le dire mais
alors en reprenant ce thème par exemple
vous dites communes tant il me reste
parce que je sais qu'il faut rendre les
restes d'un corps non non ça va là en
prenant ce thème par exemple morts
suspectes mort d'homme politique et c
est ce que au fond alors vous avez une
intention qui est louable celle de dire
la vérité
mais est ce que vous vous desservez pas
vous même en forçant parfois un peu le
trait dans ce film vous y allez fort la
diète ou témoin différentes et si je dis
la vérité ici d'abord je la connais pas
mais si je me rapproche de la vérité que
je fais un document mais les gens vont
me flinguer il
moi c'est quand même c'est quand même de
la fiction mais la fiction sa porte les
grands sujets depuis toujours les
esclavages tout a été fait pour porter
les scénarios de fiction porte les
grandes idées c'est beaucoup plus fort
de raconter l'histoire d'une belle femme
qui est beke espionne j'sais pas quoi de
faire un documentaire sur l'espionnage
alors vous vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
seul parce qu'il ya des journalistes et
des critiques dufresne dans l'express
est dithyrambique à votre égard et la
partie de foot pour ça que moi je dis
qu'il faut pas attaquer les critiques
ces gens là viennent de me sauver la vie
meilleure et là aussi qui vont qui sont
parfois aussi insultants à l'égard des
cinéastes oil & gas la peuf autre
carrière d'actrice de n'importe quoi je
m'en fous moi ils sont libres les
journalistes pourquoi ils penseraient
pâli moi je veux être libre
alors je vais pas dire un journaliste de
ne pas me dire que je fais une mère
douche et parfois non mais alors si mais
je voulais dire que certains vous m
mais dans le même temps ceux qui vous
aiment donc ya pas de suspicion à ce
propos vous reproche de pas faire une
belle lumière ne pas faire ainsi de
belles lumières j'ai des grands opéras
donnant algérien d'argent j'ai pas
d'argent d'accord mais on peut reprocher
à un clochard à deux doigts d'avoir des
souliers troué alors écoutez arrêté non
je crois que j'ai fait des films avec
beaucoup d'argent maintenant je n'en
fais pas le miraculeux temps puis marge
en agent trouble bon ça s'appelle tout
est calme ouais et ça passe donc dans
une seule salle à paris la mienne et qui
se trouve au 39 boulevard de strasbourg
le bras dit et ça coûte combien la place
35 balle pour deux films parce que j'y
rajoute un autre de mes vieux film c'est
à dire qu'on voit deux films pour trente
cinq balles comme dans le temps quand on
était petit avec pasqua voilà donc j'ai
donné l'info avec pasqua nombre d'appels
n'ont pas pu le temps la piste
alors le prochain film sur les rillettes
non mais je vais le faire mais je vais
le faire avec trois francs trois sauts
et peut-être que monsieur noir et voudra
bien me donner trois sous à moi aussi
[Musique]